bonsoir à tous au programme de cette
première journée du salon de
l'agriculture les ovins pyatt le
concours du meilleur jeune berger de
france
un concours auquel participent quatre
bourguignon est prendre au toit dont
bastien bastien un bonjour bonjour vous
êtes de saône-et-loire le concours il a
débuté dès ce matin comment ça s'est
passé pour vous pour l'instant
pour l'instant ça se passe plutôt assez
bien sauf dans la théorie mais bon on te
dit arriver quand même on vous souhaite
beaucoup de courage en tout cas les
résultats seront connus ce soir
mais pour ce salon aujourd'hui les stars
c'était évidemment les vaches
charolaises reportage madagascar
participe à son premier salon de
l'agriculture
et pourtant la génisse charolaise ne
montrent pas le moindre signe de
fébrilité
il faut dire que frédéric son éleveur
l'a bien préparé il a fallu quand même
beaucoup de bruit spéciaux à la maison
aux différents des radios spécial
différées plusieurs fois à gué du bourg
est différent avec du monde qui est
passé aussi chez nous à la maison à
l'exploitation
et donc voilà c'est papin et au bruit
elle est très gentille très docile comme
madagascar
quarante et une charolaise ont fait le
déplacement jusqu'à paris
mais la vedette du salon n'est pas
bourguignonne idéal vient du rhône
visiblement elle a tout pour plaire je
pense que idéal en fait les bien
représentatif de la race tout simplement
signé la plus grosse des vaches ni la
plus lourde mais c'est une belle
charolaise qui a vraiment la tête
représentative est courte
uf le large corne blanche orientée vers
les yeux l'égérie de chanel c'est pas
forcément miss univers est bien l'égérie
des charolaises c'est pas forcément ni
la plus grande ville à plus haut mais
c'est une belle vache qui représente
bien la race après avoir fait des belles
devant les visiteurs
les charolaises vont devoir reprendre
des forces legrand
trop de la race aura lieu dès demain
matin alors c'est sûr quand on parle de
charolais on pense beaucoup aux vaches
et pourtant il faut le savoir eh bien il
est aussi du mouton charollais qu'on
peut déguster par exemple ici sur le
stand de la région de bourgogne franche
comté avec denis or denis le boeuf
charolais l'agneau charolaise c'est la
même chose
donc c'est la même race on connaît plus
le boeuf charolais mais existe aussi le
mouton charollais qui est implantée à à
charolles l'année en charolais c'est
c'est très tendre
donkey la particularité d'avoir très peu
de gras et c'est très savoureux
traitantes très goûteux et on va on va
goûter ça en tout cas je vois qu'il ya
de très bonnes choses ici sur le stand
de la saône et loire
ben écoutez c'est le bon moment de se
quitter un je vous laisse sur ces très
belles images de gastronomie
bourguignonne époque où 3
nous on a passé une super journée bonne
soirée
non